a palavra só lhe falar que seja muito
menos havia mostrado aqui coisas que o
final isso porque eu tenho um vício que
eu descobri agora que encomendar as
coisas mais inúteis ou estudam e sífilis
é pra vocês verem que não devem comprar
não esqueceu como minha filha que o
acordo com o patrocínio é seu mora muito
obrigado afirmou mora por patrocinar
este vídeo
eu estou aqui para representar um dos
melhores e editor de vídeos para o
youtube ers hora 9
xande torpe ou para menos filmar a nova
vocês também têm essa ao filme estoques
o filme estoques é uma loja vocês têm
acesso a um monte de recursos como
enfeite de vídeo e foi de som e imagens
e mais importante que tudo tudo mas tudo
o livro de direitos autorais tanto podem
usar à vontade sim vocês podem crescer o
nosso canal no youtube até ao infinito
o filme lua nova é super fácil de usar
vocês podem arrastar arquivos
dimensionar curtar arrastar e claro
vocês podem adicionar transições ajustar
alguns elementos com o próprio filho
mora já tem esse vosso filho não tiver a
cor é 100% vocês podem usar a ferramenta
de correção de cor também se vocês
gostaram do filme o novo wii para
download está na inscrição
o cassoulet povos têm o patrocínio de
juro muito que eu faço mais filhos deste
ano em combinar coisas não esperava
estar aqui pra vocês porque só isso o
treinador é quem dá um emprego e
melhorar as coisas
então deixa muito aqui espiritual e não
sob uma novidade pra vocês pais ou não
fazer na caixa eu pietri disputar sua
voz e acabamos fazendo um quinto dos
quais os planos mais incríveis
juntamente com a esposa eo pai só neste
incrível brinquedos incrível produto é
só eu tenho isso foi mais fácil todos
que eu fui enganado não imaginam o meu
macho como é que cerca de três metros no
palco eu sou o lançamento deste jeito
nos flares vai ser feito no shopping rio
para quem não conhece é o antigo dolce
vita e nós vamos gastar 16 às 16 horas
da tarde para dar autógrafos
não voto abraços fotografias e
apresentarmos o nosso novo kit com as
áreas fabril os lares mais bem treinadas
por tanta pressão lá pessoal mas fiz
aquele que tem mais de 12 terminados e
mais do que em certas experiências que
vocês podem fazer curso área é muita
coisa tem muito menino tudo exclusivo e
toda a galera pro nosso nós já testamos
meu irmão muito certo seria mais
engraçado é que vocês podem mostrar por
exemplo vai mudar com o meu gás light
que brilha no escuro
todos em tons forma podem aceitar que
faz mais empregaram primeira coisa que
chegou à casa pensando que isso foi uma
sobrancelha golpe do qual estava
acompanha do cocó
eu comprei especificamente para apanhar
o cocal do sul que se funciona sim
quando o que cabia jair não funciona
mais volta
só tem que ocorre já está aí sim 0 desta
que volte com cinco porque às vezes
funciona três vezes não mas vamos ganhar
com sequinha ocupa papel nessa primeira
fase que vocês irem passear ou social
para quando eu faço o col vocês
ficam dizendo que somente tecnológica
que o senhor do campo pausa eu aprendi o
que é bom é que essas casas não só não
dizem tudo o que ele fez não vai perder
é não é só vocês acham que isso tem sido
é faço nenhum comentário
isso não vai acontecer vocês quiserem
que entendeu isto é também está a
apostar nas costas já está pronto mas
está feito para deixar a carne mais
tenra quando vocês fazem um churrasco
típico ocultar a canalizar é para
esquecer de falar nem imaginam skol
aí então quanto mais você morre assim
escola não fala assim está muito
estranho por corpos celestes pra mim não
vou muito ainda porque a gente está aí
mas eu acho que dificultará cada um com
faca no começo e no fim é coisa mais do
que um sempre que eu comprei um estilo
de sempre como podem pessoal 0 e por
cima de fred ter um computador digital
quanto as nossas moedas tinham mais
próxima e ou vai ver quantas moedas
ecosystem o neste caso eu tenho 291
eurose como assim não vai abrir
voltar aqui no chico neto
[Música]
a próxima e eu tenho aqui um computador
que o diâmetro das moedas e consegue
avaliar qual tipo de moeda falsa estão a
colocar em xeque a 50 cêntimos e um euro
quando colocamos aqui eu faço uma oca é
que eu levo 20 cêntimos e baixar fazer a
soma mais 20 e mais 20 cm de casa da
equipe neste no inep c é que mais 25
vezes é incrível
muito bom isso é muito incrível ainda
não 100 mil rock conta disso é que isto
quando os quatro euros
eu acho quatro de ouro quatro euros 4
dólares eu acho que só vê lo dentro está
incluído o asfalto próximo de sílvio uma
bolsinha que o congresso está bom jesus
muitas vezes você ainda que precisa ser
discutido lá não posso colocar isso aqui
e tenho que discutir com o seu bolso
isto é só plugar demandaria e não surgiu
o osso
até que o congênito ae mesmo se ficar
provado dos sintomas em duas equipes com
oito solo ainda não detém isso portanto
não vou dar uma solução mas acho que é
uma coisa que compreendam isso é um
truque de magia com músicas aí botanique
dois pauzinhos com uma música ok ok se
elas podem trocar situação ele não é o
carro agora começa agora começo a pessoa
incrível
olha aí a próxima problema aí então isso
sim calma rodas jovem tem história
entendemos que se trata de uma mosca
frente e só tem uma lógica
então você tem que duas músicas e quando
fui pra trocar roda 28 e por volta das 3
horas dentro e fora de dentro dentro e
fora deles foram expulsos há coisas
assim ó as mais rápidas
a próxima coisa que compreendeu isso aí
isso é uma branca que supostamente é uma
prévia para vocês celular em que algum
vidro partido seja do iphone a janela um
carro ou qualquer coisa assim próximo
telefone
o papa só lhe parece à partida não
comentei em baixo que o azul é pai
câmera aparece em câmera assim o que
agora parece que é uma decisão pessoal
não está muito vivo muito mal estava
muito mal tal só a fim de tomar rodando
android
brundle a funciona é pá eu acho que isso
é que funciona mais
que peixe neuzi este carros daqui outro
tem muito poder é muito pano e não tenho
não comprei essa coisa que senti não ter
parado ali sem graça não é lixo é ver a
cor e os portões já o dólar andou quanto
eu quero ter essa tecnologia agora
chama-se méxico vulto tom opel nunca e
agora tem aqui uma foto do dol que vai
avaliar essa mulher que ver se tem algum
fio alguma coisa mágica um álbum solo e
mas eu sei que é de uma cuba não pode
ser uma coisa só você que veio aqui me
falha simples
aí vou colocar o meu irmão assim vamos
derrotá lo e misteriosamente
o boneco enxergar o óbvio que o estado
pega e testemunhos legal que é isso meu
sem fios sem nada eu ficar completamente
de pé
eu não sei como é que fazem só eu não
estou vendo aqui este py cozinho este
fixing vai estar numa das nossas
crianças assistem aqui mas normalmente
esta tela sempre mais dura portanto
vocês podem ficar à vontade perto assim
devagar e já está não fica lá no e sem
incrível assuste caso de deus sul e
leste qualquer turma gente embaixo dele
o próximo encontro com maggi que
compreendeu isso foi essa coisinha por
um dólar só isso é que são sempre bem
vindos
boca puxões aqui sim aqui dentro pois
móveis
o i
a perspectiva nem parece uma cena já na
metade do tanque o que vocês jamais
legal isso formamos astrobiologia é um
orgulho pois foi isso que eu não vi o
sol não aparece e faz um toque no final
de uma perspectiva que lutou sem alma é
claro a próxima coisa que eu compreendo
isso mas para longe em uma das ruas mais
perigosas e sempre o nosso máximo mas
preto
o ex-médico país a espada df tá na hora
só para lembrar essa espada foi nos dois
não isso é bom que seja uma coisa boa
não renovou também não vai contar
[Música]
van
como assim assim o inter vai
experimentar mas deixou o campo sob o
nome de escola está mais para expansiva
olha aí ela em concórdia e aumenta
então nós vamos engolir essa percepção
que o estado é contra a boca
assim fico mais 19 dólares para a
qualidade que tem mas sim acho que não
puderam as curiosas não eu acho que as
coisas todas
não eu acho que as pessoas têm de ter um
prejuízo de até quatro elementos não
goza muito triste não o fez o dois pra
este pequeno tal não é idéia é o que eu
quero dizer é emergência em vídeo
funciona bem e vencer
mas na vida real isso é normal porque
aqui tudo
[Música]
a próxima coisa que o complexo ao não
ser que eu comprei isso não sei qual é o
lugar que eu vou dar um zoom para abrir
cadeados shiloh é uma data de chávez
infelizmente não tenho aqui um cadeado
portanto não posso fazer o teste aqui
se quiserem que eu faça um teste só pôde
havia tentado abrir qualquer coisa um
encontrou assim com esses utensílios que
tem embaixo e vou testar então que está
sob o asfalto é apenas isso realmente
funcionar mas eu acho que só tem dois
kill cada um e tentar abrir o cadeado e
deu só o nosso próximo destino do jogo
prendeu isso mais uma vez é um truque de
magia tanto pique de uma caixa preta
poderá gozar a vontade o papel ea linha
eu vou brigar aqui o baralho de cartas e
voltou à austrália primeira etapa a 17
copa secopa de 114 tocada eu vou estar
aqui
o xeque o horário local dentro desta
caixa o que vai acontecer aos sete copas
ou vá lá fora do baralho 17 o horário
não tem com qualquer hoje é y cursi uma
picada eu preciso ser nome dele na ok
mas se eu choro ao tvs o carro vai ter
um baralho aqui dentro vai voltar pra
casa só não estará mais perto pra vocês
repararem para que caixa takimura cartas
é só com o cara que o baralho estalar os
dedos e desapareceu no a baralho de
cartas
no entanto voltaram a assolar sair outra
vez o horário
assim quem quer explicação pessoal
quando nós colocamos morar dentro desta
caixa horário fica oculta sem fundo que
usam é que o horário e tem mesmo uma
carta
só que essas cartas todas são compostas
de pessoal está nos meus truques para a
escola e pessoas você mente foi incrível
próximo mas o que eu tenho aqui só esta
caixinha misteriosa piquet todas essa
caixa mágica é uma magia mas queremos
também famosa
[Aplausos]
[Risadas]
sob sol ou não isso também tem imensos
friends with só daria voz amiga nossa
mãe quando abracei a retórica e mente
dou aula mas é isso aí próximo devido à
falsa e estava com a face não vamos ter
na boca agora por cachito suzuki e eu
não lá vai ser a língua de velho está
bom é que vocês podem ficar paulo podem
fazer essas coisas podem fazer truques
de mágica com ela pra em si mesma coisa
ou inclusive já fiz dois toques com ela
só esta é a minha língua é eu explicar o
ato mesmo disse na época eu não tinha o
sonho de ver seu time 2 go e márcio como
assim a coisa mais pobre que cumpriram
este terroso ano convida conseguia
passar pela casa tipos de crimes que
nunca sempre é provar se enganaram os
nossos pais para deixar em casa por por
cento foram vocês fizeram cole minha
casa então é sempre bom é sempre bom
conhecer essa é uma das plantas mais
antigas do mundo
acho uma coisa que compreendeu isso
também foi muito barato
o dia é um rolo de fita cola mas com
fita-cola pelo choro do irã disse lula
isso é que serve pra vocês fazerem
contornam rota para uma sala ou para
usar e nuno gomes pc podem fazer fatos
que brilham no escuro também que pessoas
continuarem a equilibrar-se esperam
assim como as calças só faz só um deles
apontaram fácil vai ficar refletivo em 3
2 1 para o everton que dizer que se
reaja à lua
ae o fx estava fazendo a pulsar é muito
pouco mesmo é de sexual do dia enquanto
os quatro têm sol e luz e três fases
grande e à noite vai ficar brilhante mas
é o curto muito ainda não usei mas eu
acho que produz dólares ou 4 dólares da
opway próxima consegui compreender o
especial também à maggi eu comprei este
o ensino e pique mas tiro meu sustento o
câncer que eu vou colocar aqui na minha
mão
assim um de outro ler outro lê eu acho
que a visita do batom por seu mas não
posso faltar no show o quanto esse
segredo assim pessoal
esta é uma das regiões mais antigas do
mundo que é o the fall sei que onde eu
claramente quando ganso é só colocar no
sul e no centro do governo e voltar a
colocar aqui estátua foi outra coisa
muito tempo que eu comprei que custou 1
dólar sobe sem ficar com ela que está em
forma
[Música]
falamos todos vocês concordam em casa
este telefone 11
eu acho que sim então é fã de ter sido
enquadrado em três câmeras e não sei
quem é essa
o wii será um produto isso que o iphone
a próxima e aproxima a próxima das
pessoas que também querem ter um iphone
ou não se descuida cti exatamente ou
seja vocês têm um x max 1 x comprou e
pinga e conseguem ter a cosmética do
iphone - aí infelizmente não consegue
não não eu acho que tem a modelo os
processos que mexe com 11 mas não fica
tão bom
só quem tinha que comprar a versão preto
méxico após comprarem um onze com este
wen não é igual a não é o final das três
camas 12 ambientes são mais salientes
são muito maiores no entanto vocês
conseguem entender como é que é possível
então os quiserem não terem dinheiro pro
economista que uma solução só pela
cosmética qualquer pastor do estado
sou a favor de tops sabe aquela típica
foto espanhol assim né as pessoas sabem
que existem embora lançarem vocês
compraram luiz por 1 dólar mas a banda
ainda mais fácil e apreendeu a um
primeiro papel disse é isso é muito
curto a 1
não é pq mesmo talvez chapas pessoas
diferentes e um bom então é só nas
províncias de hoje eu não sei todas as
coisas não lixo que chegaram entretanto
que casa e ainda dá pra mim muito mais
coisas importantes se quiserem que eu
mostro aqui no canal comentem deixa
muito leque e é esse história desse tipo
de conteúdo
salma hayek pessoal já sabe consigo
treinar alguma coisa do skusa 50 santo a
igreja sempre acreditamos que em outra
coisa e não esqueçam sol e até 6 às 16
horas nós vamos estar num shopping de
gugu antigos e evita sua obra está com
vocês terá fotos livros vídeos e
apresentar o nosso novo produto o
histórias mais incríveis
muito pior é puxar o eu olho estou eu
tocaria também se pode aproveitar a
janela construir 1 mil views saltou
aumentou em uma confeitaria meus amigos